نذهب الان الى شمالي غزه دائما والدكتور
منير البرش مدير عام وزاره الصحه
الفلسطينيه ارحب بك معنا متابعتك للوضع
ايذا حياكم الله الحقيقه يعني ما حصل في
مستشفى كمال عدوان هو جريمه
حرب مكتمله الاركان عندما نتحدث ان هذه
الاله الاله
الاسرائيليه وهذا الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
يدخل
ضخمه جدا
يجرف الارشيف المركزي والصيدليه ويجرف
ايضا طيارات الاسعاف والسيارات المواطنين
وقد خرجنا من مستشفى كمال عدوان ونحن نحمل
الجثث 100 جثه اخذناها معنا من فتحه في
الور
وهؤلاء العش من الجثث كانوا قد ماتوا بسبب
الحصار العشر ايام هؤلاء لم يدخل احد من
الشهداء الى المستشفى وانما ماتوا بسبب
الحصار وبسبب القتل المتعمد فطلاق الرصاص
على الاربعه الذين تحدثنا عنهم بالامس
ماتوا
وايضا العديد من المرضى والمصابين قد
استشهدوا الحقيقه الاحتلال لم يابه بجثثهم
اخذهم معه في الجرافه وفرم جثتهم مع
السيارات وال واكان هذا المشهد الحقيقه لا
يفعله انسان ولا يفعله ادمي هذا القاتل
هذا المجرم هذا الاحتلال الذي يعني يقتل
بلا هواده نحن الحقيقه استقبلنا يعني
طواقمنا الطبيه يعني بكل فخر
واعتزاز هؤلاء الاطباء الذين صمدوا لاخر
لحظه لم يتركوا مرضاهم فكل التحيه الى
الدكتور حسام ابو صفيه والى زملائه الذين
مكثوا معه لاخ اخر لحظه وكل التحيه
والحريه للدكتور احمد الكحلوت مدير عام
المستشفى الذي اقتاده الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
امس لتعذيبه مره اخرى في فتره التحقيق لكي
يحضر اليهم التسجيلات وغير التسجيلات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي حول هذا المستشفى الى
سكنه عسكريه يريد تصفيه الوجود الصحي في
شمال غزه نحن لا نستسلم له مطلقا سنعمل
باذن الله رب العالمين انا احدثكم وانا
يعني داخل مركز جديد نفتتح للولاده مركز
العصريه للولاده لكي نخفف عن
الحاله العامه للولاده في مستشفى الصحاب
الذي استهدفه الاحتلال بالامس لكن خرج من
منه وبقي الصحابه يعمل كمركز توليد لكن في
شمال غزه لا يوجد اي مركز التوليد اي
عندما اغلقوا مستشفى كمال
عدوان وايضا مستشفى العوده الذي ما زال
محاصرا فاجتهد اليوم لفتح مركز ونقطه طبيه
جديده تسمى مركز العصريه ومن فضل الله انا
امامي الطبيبه التي يعني ولدت اكثر من
يعني ثلاث حالات في هذا اليوم واكثر من 40
حاله تم معاينتهم هم يغلقون ونحن نفتتح
باذن الله عز وجل هم يحاصرون انا ونحن
نكسر حصارهم ان ارادتنا قويه كك وادر طبيه
نعمل بجهد كبير من اجل ان شاء الله انقاذ
مرضانا نقف خدما لمرضانا
نفخر نفخر
باننا يعني خدم لهذا الشعب العظيم الذي
يعني يقاوم بكل ما اوتي من قوه وقد قتله
الاحتلال بكل عنف ولم يابه بشهيد ولا
مصاب عنف الاطباء اعتقل اي الاطباء
والكوادر الطبيه وضع كل النازحين اكثر من
7000 نازح اخذهم الى حوض من المياه الصرف
الصحي تركهم في العراء اكثر من سبع ساعات
خلع ملابسهم هؤلاء هؤلاء الاطباء الذين
ترونهم في الصوره وكان يعني الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي نشر صورهم هؤلاء من خيره
المجتمع الفلسطيني الدكتور خالد خالد
حموده هذا الاول على البورد العربي وهو
حائز على جوائز علميه عظيمه جدا يفتخر
فيها كل فلسطيني وقد استشهد اولاده واذله
الاحتلال وخلع ملابسه في العراء وهو يتكلم
ويقول انا طبيب لم يابه الاحتلال انه
طبيبا لم لم يقدر ان هذا قامه علميه لا هو
هو يريد ان يذل الكادر الطبي لكننا نقول
اننا باذن الله عز وجل سنبقى فخورين باننا
خدما لشعبنا لاخر لحظه سنلقى الله عز وجل
غير مقصرين سنلقى الله عز وجل اي ونحن
سعداء باننا نقوم بخدمه شعبنا الحقيقه هذا
ما نقوم به كك وادر طبيه كزاره صحه
فلسطينيه وباذن الله لن نستسلم هذا العدو
الحاقد الذي يريد قتل كل المنظومه الطبيه
ان ان قتل منا اعدادا او اعتقل منا اعدادا
سنبقى ان شاء الله نفتتح مراكز طبيه ونقاط
طبيه ونعالج ابنائنا المحاصرين والمظلومين
باذن الله عز وجل دكتور كنت قد تحدثت عن
اعداد النازحين واعداد الضحايا يعني هل من
احصائيات ربما في هذه المرحله يمكن الحديث
عن احصاءات رسميه بشان هذه الكارثه تحديدا
في كمال عدوان
الحقيقه ما زالت الجريمه تتضح يوما بعد
يوم
و اليوم كانت كتبان رمليه حول المستشفى
منعتنا من دخول السيارات بشكل مباشر
احضرنا جرافات لفتح الطريق المشاهد كانت
مؤلمه جدا جدا لم لم نتفق من الصدمه حتى
يعني نستطيع ان نحصر في الايام القادمه
سيكون لدينا من التقارير الواضحه بهذا
المشهد العدواني
اي تجريف الاحتلال للمولدات الكهربائيه
ومحطات الاكسجين والصيدليه المركزيه
والارشيف المركزي
اي يعني انه لا يريد لكمال عدوان كمستشفى
ان يعمل مجددا اي محاوله لهذا المستشفى
لابد ان تبوء بالفشل هو يقول ذلك لكن سترى
في الايام الايام القادمه اننا سنعمل على
تشغيل مستشفى كمال عدوان باذن الله عز وجل
بكوادر مستشفى كمال عدوان الذين صمدوا
طيله هذه الايام العشره وهم يتحدون
الاحتلال ويقولون نحن موجودين مع اطفالنا
لن نترك اطفالنا اكثر من 12 طفل صغير من
بينهم اثنين من الاطفال بقوا معهم هذا
الطاقم يدافع عنهم ويعطيهم الحليب وكان
الدكتور حسام يبحث عن
يعني قطره ماء مفلتره من اجل حليب الاطفال
حكى لي وهو يتكلم بهذا الخصوص يبحث ما بين
النازحين هل لديكم ماء مقطرات الحقيقه
الجهد الذي بذل الجهد يستحقه شعبنا ونحن
نقول باذن الله عز وجل سنبقى سنبقى بجانب
شعبنا نعالجهم ونداوي ونطبق و ونعمل باذن
الله عز وجل بما يرضيهم ويرضي الله عز وجل
ا طبعا دكتور الصدمات تتوالى وانتم تنوون
اذا العوده وعدم الاستسلام للعمل في هذا
المستشفى يعني هل تنوون القيام ربما باي
خطوات او اجراءات بشكل رسمي يعني اثر ما
حصل لابد من توثيق هذه الجريمه الحرب من
قبل المؤسسات القانونيه
وقتل
الجرحى والمصابين
ودهسه جرافات
وايضا دفن الشهداء الع الموجودين في ساحه
المستشفى وسحبهم بالجرافات
وايضا تدمير البنى التحتيه لمستشفى رسمي
قانوني اي لديه اعتراف دولي من منظمه
الصحه العالميه المبنى المبنى بني في
تمويل من منظمه الصحه العالميه وايضا
الطوابق العليا من مؤسسات دوليه تعمل بشكل
واضح والصليب الاحمر وكل المؤسسات الدوليه
لمستشفى كمال عدوان فلذلك هذا الامر يتوجب
على المؤسسات الحقوقيه ان توثقه توثيقا
صحيحا من اجل
اي رفع قضايا دوليه على هذا المحتل المجرم
ان كان اي يعني هناك حساب في في الدنيا
وهناك مؤسسات ما زالت تحترم نفسها وتحترم
القانون الدولي لكننا لن نترك جرائم
الاحتلال تمر هباء ولن يعني نتركهم يهربوا
بفعلتهم الشنيعه في قتل اطفالنا وقتل
مصابينا وجرحانا القانون الدولي واتفاقيه
جنيف الرابعه وملحقات اتفاقيه جنيف
الرابعه كلها ضمنت حق العلاج وحق التداوي
وحق الحمايه كل هذا نص عليه القانون لكن
السؤال الكبير الذي يطرح نفسه هل هذه
المؤسسات الدوليه استطاعت ان تحمي تحمي
قانونها هل استطاعت ان تنفذ ما ما انشئ من
اجله هذا سؤال كبير لابد ان يجاوب هذا
العالم عليه وان يصاغ هذا العالم من جديد
لا ان ينظر بعين عوراء هنا في غزه هذا قتل
بربري وهذا قتل حضاري وهذا سلاح ذكي وهذا
سلاح غبي الحقيقه دم الانسان هو اغلى ما
نملك دم
الانسان بشتى انواعه بكل دياناته هو انسان
يستحق التقديس ويستحق الكرامه فلذلك لابد
الجميع ان يتكاتف لحمايه الانسان كونه
انسان لانه اعظم شيء في الوجود خلق
الانسان فلذلك الله عز وجل وضع للانسان
حرمه وقداسه للاسف هؤلاء لم يرعوا قداسه
الانسان فجرف جرفه تصور دبابه 80 طن تجرف
شهيدا على الارض تصور ماذا تفعل تفعل به
تصور هذه الدبابه اسف الجرافه
الكبيره تسير فوق جثث الشهداء في مستشفى
كمال عدوان و وتفرم مع باقي المباني
والمولدات ومحطات الاكسجين انا لم ارى في
حياتي اضخم من هذا الشيء الذي يمشي على
الارض هي هي عماره من اربع طوابق تسير على
الارض وتاخذ كل كل كل شيء امامها فلذلك
فلذلك لابد المجتمع الدولي ان يعرف ان
هناك جريمه حرب ارتكبت في مستشفى كمال
العدوان وارتكبت في مستشفى الاندونيسي
واليوم ال التخوف الكبير انه ما فعل في
الاندونيسي كمستشفى وما فعل في كمال عدوان
كمستشفى ان يفعل في مستشفى العوده الذي ما
زال محاصرا حتى اللحظه وقناصه الاحتلال
على جميع المباني لا ترحم اي انسان فيهم
ان ان يخرج من راسه راسه من الشباك يطلقون
الرصاص بكثافه في هذا المربع يمنعون ايضا
العلاج والماء والغذاء على دخوله على
الكوادر الطبيه وهناك استغاثات كبيره في
هذا الامر نسال الله عز وجل ان يحمي شعبنا
نسال الله عز وجل ان يحفظ ابنائنا
وكوادرنا الطبيه
شكرا الله عز وجل ان
ير شكرا لك مدير عام وزاره الصحه
الفلسطينيه الدكتور منير البرش الذي كان
معنا من شمالي غزه